today i'm going to be talking about
pooping yep we're going to learn how to
poop more frequently and healthily for
some going to the toilet in the morning
is their worst experience of the day
they may spend more than 10 minutes on
the toilet seat
trying really hard to push but nothing
seems to come out because everything is
blocked there are many factors that can
cause constipation some of the most
common reasons include severe stress a
poor diet lack of exercise lack of sleep
dehydration and even a change of
environment or time zone due to
traveling here's a fun fact did you know
that women suffer more from constipation
than men
this could be due to the slower movement
of food through a woman's intestines as
well as the effects of female hormones
on the gi tract constipation is
especially common in the days leading up
to menstruation during pregnancy and
even after menopause so how frequently
should you go to the toilet there is no
one straight answer as each individual's
bowel movement is different for some
it's on a daily basis some might even go
up to three times a day whereas for
others it could be on alternate days
however if you have less than three
bowel movements a week and your stools
are dry
hard and difficult to pass
you're likely constipated i've done
several videos in the past talking about
how important it is to have a healthy
gut because your gut is your second
brain your gut health does not only
affect you physically but also mentally
and emotionally i'm sure when you have
been constipated for several days your
abdomen feels bloated and extremely
uncomfortable making you agitated and
even moody all of us do face
constipation occasionally but if you're
someone who has to deal with it almost
on a regular basis then try doing these
seven things to help relieve
constipation naturally
our body is made up of 60 fluid drinking
enough water is extremely important to
keep everything moving in your digestive
tract just think of your colon like a
tube imagine that you're eating all
these foods and they go into this tube
but there isn't enough water to push the
food down through the tube hence
everything will start to get blocked and
eventually harden drinking warm water
helps to break down food faster than
drinking cold water hence helping you to
go to the bathroom more easily and
reduce constipation
if you're saying that warm water doesn't
even help you
then the next step you can try is to
drink a cup of hot coffee for some
people including myself consuming coffee
can increase the urge to go to the
bathroom this is because coffee
stimulates the muscles in the digestive
system to contract causing a bowel
movement in fact a study found that the
effect of coffee is 60 stronger than
drinking water so if i'm really
struggling to go to the bathroom and a
cup of warm water just doesn't do it i
would drink a cup of hot coffee in the
morning and it works almost instantly
coffee also contains small amounts of
soluble fibers that can help prevent
constipation by improving the balance of
gut bacteria saying that however for
those suffering with ibs caffeine could
over stimulate your bowel making the
digestive symptom worse so this method
might not be for everyone depending on
your digestive health but caffeine
certainly does help to relieve
constipation especially for me
just like eating sleeping and exercising
you need to establish a poop routine as
well for most people including myself i
would go to the toilet first thing in
the morning for some it might be at the
end of their day choose whatever works
for you but you need to have a bowel
movement at the same time every day and
it needs to be at a time where you don't
feel rushed if i have a rushed morning
i'm not going to be able to poop
everything is just going to be blocked
up and i will feel constipated later on
hence i'll get up at least one hour
earlier every morning before leaving
home to make sure that my toilet
experience is relaxing and flush
everything out even before i consume
breakfast for some of you eating a small
breakfast can help to stimulate the
gastrocolic reflex which can help waste
move through your colon so you might try
going to the bathroom 15 to 45 minutes
after breakfast but avoid having a heavy
breakfast because that could slow down
your digestion and cause constipation
did you know that your toilet posture
could also cause constipation let's
first take a look at our standard
sitting toilet posture typically a
person sits on a western toilet bowl
just like how he would sit on a chair
the position is basically at a 90 degree
position where your hips are bent while
sitting on your toilet is comfortable
the placement of your upper legs at 90
degrees to your abdomen disrupt the
passage of your intestines making having
a bowel movement more difficult some of
you might find yourself bending your
upper body forward while sitting
thinking that it can help with your
bowel movement in fact it blocks it even
further the natural human impulse is to
squat while emptying the bowels i'm sure
some of you might have seen and even use
those squatting type toilet bowls in
fact my grandmother is still using it
and it's still pretty common in asia
when you're in a squatting position your
knees are brought closer to your abdomen
positioning your organs and muscles in a
way that relaxes your rectum in a
straight line this maximizes the
efficiency of your bowel movement of
course
you can't be squatting on your regular
toilet bowl it's just dangerous
so what you can do is to place a low
stool in front of your toilet seat and
place your feet on the stool this will
help achieve the 35 degree hip angle
that does not constrict your rectum and
allow the stool to pass more smoothly
i know some of you might be thinking i
can't believe she just taught me the
signs on how to poop correctly well it
really does work and it's worth trying
to see if it helps you that's why you'll
find a low stool in my house
i'm sure you've heard this too many
times if you can't go to the toilet eat
more vegetables and fruits this is
because dietary fiber increases the size
of your stools makes them softer and
easier to pass the general
recommendation for dietary fiber intake
is 25 grams for women and 38 grams for
men daily if you don't consume enough
fiber in your diet start adding more
high fiber foods to your meals including
fruits vegetables beans and whole grain
breads and cereals but add it in slowly
if you start eating too much at once
this can actually cause constipation if
however you're telling me that i do
consume more than enough fiber yet i'm
always bloated and constipated here's
what you need to know
having too much fiber in your diet can
also cause bloating
gas and constipation this is especially
uncommon if you're someone who is
following a vegan or a raw diet
fiber is vital for healthy solid bowel
movements however eating more than 70
grams of fiber a day can cause bloating
and constipation so
don't overdo it
of the reasons why you have digestive
issues is because of an imbalance in the
bacteria that live naturally in your
intestines we need both pre and
probiotics to keep your immune system
strong and to support your overall
digestive health probiotics are made up
of good bacteria that helps keep your
body healthy and working well
probiotics are live bacteria cultures
that we consume in fermented foods or in
supplements fermented foods which are
rich in probiotics include yogurt
tempeh aged cheese kefir sauerkraut
pickles kombucha natto and my favorite
kimchi and miso while probiotic foods
have live bacteria prebiotic foods feed
the good bacteria that already live in
your gut foods rich in prebiotics
include banana
apple barley oats seaweed asparagus
garlic
onions jerusalem artichokes and honey
i can't emphasize enough about the
importance of regular exercise to your
overall well-being
muscular contraction is directly related
to blood flow
less blood flow will mean weaker
contractions which equals slower food
transit time when you exercise
especially performing cardio training
you increase the blood flow in your body
hence stronger blood flow pumps through
the intestinal muscles this helps to
stimulate the natural contraction of
muscles in your intestines and decrease
the transit time of food passing through
your intestine it doesn't have to be a
long or vigorous workout session even a
short 15 to 30 minutes morning walk can
help keep the digestive tract healthy
stretching and even practicing yoga may
also ease constipation certain yoga
poses can be helpful because they reduce
stress and increase blood flow to the
digestive tract which stimulates the
intestines to contract one of the yoga
poses include the deep yoga squat which
mimic the squatting position of passing
stool
so these are 7 simple tips to help
relieve constipation naturally try them
out and let me know what works best for
you it is important to also remember
that your digestive health still comes
down to your overall lifestyle eat a
well-balanced diet and avoid greasy or
fatty foods reduce your intake of fast
foods alcohol and soft drinks get enough
rest daily and move daily do things that
will reduce your stress levels
occasional constipation is normal but if
you experience pain every time you go to
the toilet then speak to your doctor if
you're concerned about your ongoing
constipation if you find this video to
be useful then do give this video a
thumbs up share this video on to your
family members and friends and don't
forget to hit the subscribe button if
you haven't yet subscribed and you will
find lots of home workouts healthy
recipes workout plan meal plan as well
as fitness tips on my youtube channel
and let me know how your pooping ritual
is like in the comments below and i will
see you next time all the best